well one of Alex's get ready with me
post that went viral oh this is amazing
was her getting ready for a Miami
Dolphins game so let's see that I love
it I have this tiny little Jimmy chew
bag which I think goes with the heels
feel like a mom picking up her kids from
school
we I'm like okay I love that you think a
mom could look like that together
picking up I know it was amazing but so
the mom the mom's k they came out right
the mom tumbled me very quickly they
were like girl yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is on the way to school this is
this is them on
the okay so this is me after yes yeah
this is you
see this
is this is me this is after sleeping
with your children
and they they kick you all night and
it's super fun no I my goal is to look
like you in that video at some
[Music]
[Applause]
point Thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home